good evening everyone and welcome to
Tucker Carlson tonight I'm Tulsi gabbard
standing in for Tucker at this point in
time it looks like Republicans are going
to take control of the House of
Representatives while Democrats will
hold on to the Senate now we've spent
all week hearing nothing but pundits
pontificating on what actually happened
in this election but if you're like me
you've had enough of that it's time for
us to talk about what happens next it's
time for those who actually got elected
to prove to the American people that
they're not just politicians that they
actually are there in Washington to take
action to protect the interests and
freedom of the American people
unfortunately while in Bali today
instead of delivering a necessary
message of unity to all Americans
President Biden chose to attack half the
country once again implying that the
only acceptable Democratic outcome is a
win for the Democratic Party
let me start with a few words about the
recent elections held in the United
States
what we saw was the strength and
resilience of the American democracy and
we saw it in action
and the American people proved once
again that democracy is Who We Are
there's a strong rejection of election
deniers at every level from those
seeking the lead to our states
and those are seeking to serve in
Congress and also those seeking to
oversee the elections
and there was a strong rejection of
political violence and voter
intimidation
there were no candidates this cycle that
were in favor of political violence or
voter intimidation or destroying
democracy
Joe Biden's message is the wrong
approach because here's the truth as
long as the Democratic Party in the
permanent Washington Elite are working
hand in hand with Google and Facebook
and as long as Google is allowed to
continue to use its Monopoly power to
skew public opinion in a certain
direction literally manipulating the
information that we as voters are
allowed to see then there is no
democracy
a recent study by researchers at North
Carolina State University found that
Google's email service Gmail quote
retained the majority of left-wing
candidate emails while sending quote the
majority of right-wing candidate emails
to the spam folder
additionally Google has greatly reduced
the visibility of various conservative
websites in its search results
a Breitbart for example found that
Google has changed its algorithm so that
search traffic to Breitbart declined by
more than 60 percent
as you can see these kinds of changes
can have a major impact on voting a
peer-reviewed 2015 study published in
the proceedings of the National Academy
of Sciences found that big search
engines like Google can influence the
voting preferences of undecided voters
by 20 percent or more
we've been hearing a lot of politicians
Scream and Shout about how committed
they are to defending our democracy
stop posturing stop fear-mongering do
something about it that's what we need
right now leaders who are actually
serious about working on behalf of their
constituents and the American people and
finding common sense solutions to the
many challenges that we face
now the reality is the margins of this
election across the board are razor thin
no matter how things shake out in the
next few days with these election
results that have not yet been announced
Republicans and Democrats will have to
find a way to work together if there's
any hope of getting anything done
unfortunately what we're already seeing
is both sides hardening their position
we the American people cannot afford for
Congress to be paralyzed by partisan
gridlock for the next two years there's
too much to be done
every person in Congress should see
themselves as an independent who is not
beholden to any political party but
beholden only to their constituents the
American people ready and willing to
work with their colleagues
it won't be easy I know it's going to
require leadership courage respect and
humility
when I was a democrat in Congress and I
introduced legislation I always sought
out and was able to find Republicans and
Democrats who were willing to work
together on actually solving problems
it's hard but it can be done it must be
done
I'm not advocating bipartisanship just
for the sake of bipartisanship it's
really about coming together as
Americans to work for the best interests
of the people that they serve us their
constituents
there are many challenges that we're
facing here are a few ways where
Congress should make a start
now first and foremost we must secure
our borders we have to use the power of
the purse to close the border and make
it crystal clear that if you've come
into this country illegally through
Biden's open door you got to go back to
wherever you came from if you want to
come back into our country you've got to
follow our laws
now just a few weeks ago I was in
McAllen Texas Southern most border the
busiest spot of the Southern border for
illegal Crossings where congresswoman
Myra Flores and her husband Customs and
Border Patrol agent we walked around and
they showed me one of the spots where
there's this huge gap in the border wall
later as we were driving out we saw
piles and piles of building materials
that were purchased for the wall so
stacked on the side of the road unused
things that we already paid for so I
asked why aren't they being used well
the Biden Administration won't allow
continued construction of the wall but
they also won't allow the governor of
Texas to use those materials again that
we already bought to secure their own
border
unfortunately what's happening in
McAllen is occurring all along the
southern border Fox's Bill malusion
reported this weekend from Normandy
Texas as well as Eagle Pass
in Normandy Texas early Wednesday
morning a massive group of migrants
crosses illegally into this tiny town on
the outskirts of Eagle Pass hundreds of
them escorted by the Texas National
Guard and border patrol in a single file
line stretching almost as far as the eye
can see
Nicaragua the migrants are predominantly
from countries that title 42 a policy
that allows authorities to expel
migrants on the basis of Public Health
is rarely enforced on meaning they won't
be expelled to Mexico at the same time
another group of 400 crossed illegally
into Eagle Pass most of them single
adult men
over the weekend the White House forced
the resignation of the commissioner of
U.S Customs and Border Protection Chris
Magnus but let's be honest here what
this really was it was an effort to
shift blame away from those in power who
are the ones responsible for over 2
million people illegally entering our
country through the southern border the
president the vice president and
secretary mayorkas we can't let them get
away with this so the question is is the
Biden Administration really going to
actually change its policy and make it
clear to people around the world that
anyone who comes into this country
illegally is going to be sent
immediately back to where they came from
honestly I don't have much faith that
this is going to happen because if it
were they would have already done it
there is nothing more important than
this country than protecting our
god-given rights enshrined in the
Constitution
these very freedoms and civil liberties
however are under attack they have been
for quite some time this new Congress
coming in must take this promise that
they make when they take their oath of
office seriously to support and defend
the Constitution of the United States
and actually work together to protect
our civil liberties and end the gross
overreach of government get rid of
Provisions like those in the Patriot Act
that allow for secret fisa courts that
allow for warrantless wiretapping of
Americans allow for a no-fly list that
is no due process the use of the
Espionage Act to go after political
dissidence and more
they need to exercise their oversight
authority to stop this administration's
efforts to undermine our freedom of
speech and silencing political opponents
by politicizing agencies like the
Department of Justice and FBI to go
after them and by getting big Tech and
social media to censor voices that they
don't want to hear
a recent lawsuit by the states of
Missouri and Louisiana have uncovered
troubling evidence that this censorship
is occurring
a Twitter even scheduled a meeting to
debrief top White House officials on
quote-unquote vaccine misinformation
Twitter then censored that quote-unquote
misinformation some of which later
turned out to be true
in a particularly egregious case
officials at the White House and Pfizer
urged Twitter to ban journalists Alex
Berenson because he pointed out
accurately and correctly that coveted
vaccines don't stop transmission of the
virus
now baronson's lawsuit Unearthed
internal Communications at Twitter
talking at an April 2021 meeting at the
White House one Twitter employee writing
that the White House quote really wanted
to know about Alex Berenson
another Twitter employee wrote quote
White House coveted advisor Andy slavitt
suggested they had seen data that had
showed Berenson was the epicenter of
disinfo that radiated outwards to the
persuadable public
now within months Twitter banned Alex
Berenson Facebook meanwhile took down a
parody account of Tony fauci after the
White House complained
meanwhile the Department of Homeland
Security's domestic Terror unit is
targeting parents who were protesting at
Board of Education meetings because
they're concerned about their kids
education
they dragged non-violent pro-life
activists from their homes in front of
their kids
but if you're not going to let me then
I'll just no I want
my door with
[Applause]
it
you're not gonna tell me anything
can I have your name
you're not gonna give me your name
you're not gonna give me any information
when my kids go out to the car to go to
school and the FBI pulls up
armed running to the door and one of
them goes to the kids and holds the kids
with a long gun
a side of my driveway and does not let
them go into the house that is
absolutely as my wife said in the video
unacceptable
now instead of curbing these abuses of
power Congress has enabled them
in order to prevent further abuse of
power Congress needs to use the power of
the purse and immediately halt the IRS
funding of 87 000 new IRS agents that
will be harassing everyday Americans now
the IRS has a troubling history of
targeting groups and individuals based
on their politics you probably remember
IRS director Lois Lerner specifically
targeted conservatives Congress did
nothing to hold her accountable
now they must take action now before
it's too late because the IRS is now
already one of the most heavily armed
law enforcement agencies in the country
listen to be an accountants were also
Law Enforcement Officers which is very
interesting because a lot of the special
agents that work for the IRS they don't
come from a law enforcement background
we get to do the same things like all
the other law enforcement officers do
things happen we have to be able to
respond so we have to be ready so we
teach our agents to fire a firearm to be
able to shoot we teach them defensive
tactics and methods of Defending
themselves and protecting others as well
so they go through that entire process
so that not only can they analyze
records but they also have that law
enforcement component we do carry
weapons we carry handcuffs
why in the world do IRS agents need to
carry weapons and handcuffs most of
their work concerned civil matters not
apprehending violent criminals
now last but not least it's important
that we remember that foreign policy is
domestic policy we have politicians from
both political parties who are the
permanent Washington Elite and who must
be held accountable for what they're
doing with our taxpayer dollars and how
they're undermining our national
security as they push us closer and
closer to the brink of nuclear
catastrophe
they need to stop giving a blank check
to Ukraine and demand accountability for
the tens of billions of dollars that
they've sent so far
because the blank check it's not just
for Ukraine it's for the military
industrial complex who's made trillions
of dollars off of our wars in
Afghanistan and the Middle East
now the Biden Administration they want
to hire 87 000 new IRS agents to go over
every receipt and every deductible of
American taxpayers with a fine-tooth
comb squeezing every penny that they can
the Ukrainian government and their
corrupt bureaucrats and oligarchs and
the defense contractors who are
profiting from all these weapons the
Biden Administration requires no
receipts at all
why is this
it's because they know that most of this
money our taxpayer dollars is going to
corrupt bureaucrats
they know this their actions expose who
they really care about it's not us
while they're shipping troops and
taxpayer dollars overseas and they are
continuing to do so this Administration
in Congress are failing to take care of
our veterans and service members
as we speak here we have soldiers who
are forced to rely on food stamps to
feed their families soldiers who are
living in uninhabitable conditions and
those who are not getting the care that
they need for service-related injuries
illnesses and diseases
if the new Congress takes action on all
of these areas if they solve the Border
crisis close the border if they curb
Department of Justice abuse of power if
they shut down this new IRS funding for
hiring agents and protect civil
liberties and this unconditional endless
funding of the war in Ukraine and
protect and take care of our troops and
Veterans here at home they will have
accomplished meaningful results for the
American people
that's the right approach regardless of
which party controls Congress
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight